Danger, Will Robinson...your final season
is approaching.
"That was a joke."
"Yeah, no, I know."
Netflix has announced that Lost in Space,
the modern re-imagining of the classic '60s
TV series, will come to an end after its upcoming
third season.
The final go-round is expected to hit the
streamer sometime in 2021.
"Well, that's too bad."
The sci-fi revival got off to a bit of a rough
start when it debuted in April of 2018.
Critics generally agreed that it looked gorgeous
and was well-acted by its formidable cast.
The first season, however, was taken to task
in some quarters for not having the narrative
ambition to match its impressive visuals.
"What happened?"
"There was an accident."
The second season, debuting in December 2019,
was received much more warmly.
Critics appreciated the added dramatic heft
that batch of episodes brought to the story
of the marooned Robinson family, and the special
effects were even more stunning and elaborate
than in the first outing.
Viewers ready for some binge-watching over
the holiday season also flocked to the series,
making a third season all but inevitable.
So it was somewhat unexpected that Season
3 would actually be the series' last.
Fortunately for the show's fans, however,
this wasn't really an unexpected development.
According to producer and showrunner Zack
Estrin, Netflix didn't exactly pull the plug
on Lost in Space; the streamer simply followed
the plan which Estrin and crew had had all
along.
"Cool."
"No.
Not cool."
In a statement following Netflix's announcement,
Estrin indicated that he had always had a
clear picture in his head of where the Robinson
family's adventures would take them, and how
their story would eventually conclude.
The statement explained,
"From the beginning, we've always viewed this
particular story of the Robinsons as a trilogy,
a three-part epic family adventure with a
clear beginning, middle, and end.
It's also worth noting that, with what these
characters go through just trying to survive
each episode, if anyone deserves to catch
their breath before their next mission, it's
Will, Penny, Judy, Maureen, John, Don West,
Dr. Smith...and The Robot.
And, of course, Debbie the Chicken.
So while this chapter of Lost In Space is
coming to a rousing conclusion, I'm excited
about continuing to explore new stories with
my friends at Netflix, and for all of the
incredible possibilities that lie ahead."
While it may be a bit disappointing for fans
that Lost in Space will be coming to a close
just as it appears to be picking up a head
of steam, there's definitely something to
be said for the series' creative team having
such a strong vision for its narrative.
Sure, with such a potentially open-ended premise,
a show like Lost in Space could potentially
go on for season after season, but more often
than not, this is a recipe for even the most
well-received shows to wear out their welcome.
Fans can at least be reasonably assured that
Estrin and company will end the series on
a high note, and that the Robinson family
will find closure in the final chapters of
their story.
Estrin may not exactly be a household name,
but he has a pretty sterling record as a television
producer and writer.
He cut his teeth on the series Charmed and
Dawson's Creek, and was also an executive
producer on Prison Break, which ran for 5
seasons beginning in 2005.
Since then, Estrin has taken on a producing
role on a number of genre series, including
ABC's The River, Zero Hour, and Once Upon
a Time in Wonderland.
Netflix was satisfied enough with the performance
of Lost in Space that, in conjunction with
the announcement of the series' discontinuation,
it was also revealed that Estrin has signed
an multi-year overall deal to develop and
produce new content for the streamer.
So, while fans of Lost in Space may be lamenting
the series' end, there are a couple of pretty
awesome takeaways here: first, that the series
will receive a planned, epic conclusion; and
second, that its driving creative force will
be back with more serialized goodness in the
very near future.
Of course, we'll be keeping an eye out for
Estrin's upcoming projects to hit the Netflix
pipeline, and we'll be sure to keep you informed.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.